[Musique]
dans les années 80 mon pays a traversé
une période d'instabilité profonde
concrètement mon pays était en guerre
civile
mais pudiquement quand on parle
aujourd'hui de cette période on dit les
événements à vrai dire
ce mot valise m'a toujours interrogé
mais je ne sais pas ce qui s'est passé
et personne ne le sait vraiment où tout
au mieux chacun on possède un tout petit
morceau
partout dans le monde les pas ces
problématiques sont nombreux ils sont
enfouis dans les tiroirs des musées aux
côtés de la mémoire des colonisés des
tortures et des opprimés
aujourd'hui en nouvelle calédonie de
refont surface dans les discours
politiques sur les plateaux télévisés
ils sont présents à l'école dans les
conflits des enfants il résonne dans la
rue lors de manifestations ils sont
présents dans les murmures des vieux
comme on dit sur nouvelle calédonie
s'est passé problématique ressurgissent
parce que le temps ne suffit pas à faire
disparaître la douleur
il faut les soigner
mais comment faire
après avoir tué de nombreuses et les
options est il possible de rétablir
cette vérité qui dérange
restituer au peuple colonisé et opprimés
leur mémoire est un passage obligé
le but n'est pas de juger s'est passé ni
de les comparer une vous ni moi ne
pouvons nous inventer juges de la cour
pénale internationale
mais nous pouvons regarder ces
situations en face nous pouvons faire
par exemple en sorte qu'un petit garçon
de 3 ans née pendant la shoah avec comme
seul tort d'être juifs
ne grandissent pas avec comme seul
objectif
la vengeance de sa mère
en nouvelle calédonie on essaie
péniblement laborieusement
maladroitement parfois d'avancé
les néo calédoniens appel aux futurs
mais de quel futur peut-on rêver avec
ses plaies toujours ouverte
cette période dite des événements a été
un traumatisme pour de nombreux néo
calédonien que ce soit pour les
descendants de bagnards comme moi
certains délégitimer de leurs terres
les japonais les populations kanakes
dans la dignité a été bafouée
les vietnamiens tels contrats de chair
humaine les océaniens tous
tout le monde à sa manière renferme sans
traumatisme
à tel point qu'on aperçoit encore ce
boulet
se passe et enchaîner à certaines
chevilles comme du temps des bagnards
en 88 puis en 98 la nouvelle calédonie a
fait le choix de signer des accords
mais ils n'ont pas permis de réconcilier
les mémoires
une de mes profs me disait souvent la
mémoire n'est pas le reflet exact est
parfait du passé elle en est une trace
ainsi la mémoire et malléable pour tian
à mogi biaisé fo s'est reconstruite mais
surtout
elle est propre à chacun
il ya donc différents types de mémoire
et la mémoire individuelle c'est à dire
la mienne la vôtre monsieur ou la vôtre
madame lors d'un repas de famille on
s'est tous déjà dit il raconte n'importe
quoi le vieux temps
alors oui dans certains cas de 30 ans
raconte n'importe quoi
mais dans d'autres cas quand on est
persuadé de raconter la vérité sa vérité
sa perception son vécu sa mémoire à lui
dans la grande histoire
mais personne ne peut enlever attentons
son souvenir soit biaisée ou non
alors imaginez vous ce que ça peut
donner à l'échelle d'un pays tout entier
à l'échelle d'une nation
puis il ya la mémoire
collective c'est celle qui est
communément admise sans trop de
variantes par exemple si on parle de
foot que je vous dise coupe du monde
vous me répondrez 98 et pour certains
2018 mais d'abord 98 faire le temps joue
un rôle primordial dans la mémoire
collective
donc ces mémoires sont mouvantes
enfin il ya la mémoire officielle
c'est celle que les autorités nous
transmettre via les manuels scolaires ou
les commémorations par exemple si on
parle de la seconde guerre mondiale on
pense directement aux six millions de
juifs tués hitler des camps de
concentration
par contre les anecdotes personnelles de
la guerre reste des mémoires
individuelles
lorsqu'elle est partagée de tous et la
mémoire officielle devient alors
histoire avec un grand h est symbole
d'identité nationale
mais que se passe-t-il lorsque les
mémoires sont manipulés lorsque tonton
mans volontairement en omettant ou en
accentuant tout ou une partie de ce qui
s'est réellement passé
lorsque les autorités imposent la
version officielle
alors en général elles ne parviennent
pas à effacer nos souvenirs
la mémoire officielle les prend pas le
dessus sur la mémoire individuelle
si les autorités imposent la version
officielle il ya conflit des mémoires
mais nous aussi nous manipulons les
mémoires volontairement
mais lorsque l'on refuse de parler ou de
se souvenir du passé
nous les manipulent ont
le temps est long
il est nécessaire et ce conte en
génération
mais à lucelle
il ne suffit pas
le simple fait d'attendre que les
victimes passent à autre chose ne marche
pas
c'est même pire
aux enfants ont peint j'ai été bien
souvent pour les protéger mais
inconsciemment on leur transmet nos
émotions ils les vivent ils les piles
tive alors même que ce ne sont pas les
leurs et les générations passent la
haine et la volonté de vengeance demeure
parfois même grandissent et le vivre
ensemble est de moins en moins possible
et comment faire alors pour estomper
cette douleur
pour décharger les épaules de nos gènes
de ces émotions qui ne leur
appartiennent pas
c'est là tout l'objet de mes recherches
les études de réconciliation
les processus de réparation post conflit
la mémoire collective
au lendemain d'un conflit armé d'une
colonisation d'une guerre civile les
bourreaux sont si nombreux qu'il serait
impossible de tous les emprisonnés
pour permettre de vivre ensemble les
états amitiés ses bourreaux mais ça crée
une nouvelle sorte d'impunité
heureusement
d'autres méthodes existent
notamment
la justice transitionnelle
elle repose sur cinq piliers
la vérité
la justice
la réparation
la garantie de non répétition
et la mémoire
l'un ne peut aller sans l'autre
concernant les processus de réparation
quatre étapes sont nécessaires
d'abord la reconnaissance publique
voilà ce qu'il s'est passé
puis la responsabilité endosser le rôle
d' anciens bourreaux c'est moi qui ai
fait ça
ensuite la question du pardon les
excuses et enfin la réparation
matérielle
donc symbolique car aucune compensation
ne viendra remplacer la perte d'un
proche ça peut être une compensation
financière une commémoration un monument
aux morts une restitution
d'ailleurs
de nombreux essais ont été effectués
dans le monde en utilisant cette justice
transitionnelle
alors concrètement
ça ressemble à quoi la justice
transitionnelle
au rwanda ce sont des gars de chez jack
lang était utilisé il s'agit d'une
pratique ancestrale en 2001 on a utilisé
les gatchatcha dans le conflit des
mémoires présent depuis le génocide
imaginez-vous on a réuni sur les lieux
mêmes des cris victime encore rescapés
et bourreau afin de débattre de ce qui
s'était passé et obtenir la vérité
les débats étaient encadrés par des
personnes intègres
le but avait le pardon il
s'agissait de faire éclater la vérité
accélérer les procès et mettre fin à
l'impunité
pour encourager la réconciliation
l'édile le bourreau pouvaient bénéficier
d'une réduction de peine et la victime
de son droit à la vérité
en nouvelle zélande le peuple mahorais a
été colonisé par les anglais en 1975
c'est un tribunal un peu spécial qui est
mis en place le tribunal de white
anglais
inspiré par le mouvement noir des droits
civiques aux états-unis le peuplement
auguste est soulevée au sein même de ce
tribunal ils pouvaient déposer des
requêtes comme une sorte de commission
d' enquête permanente ils étaient
auditionnés dans des marae un peu comme
des casses traditionnels
et la couronne signer des actes du
règlement qui est engagé une
reconnaissance
des excuses officielles et des
réparations aux tribus parfois matériel
parfois financière
et il en existe bien d'autres des
exemples le comité vérité réconciliation
en afrique du sud l'instance v et et
dignité en tunisie
les caravanes espagnol de la mémoire
alors bien sûr il est impossible de
comparer ces différentes méthodes
à chaque pays son traumatisme
à chaque pays sa douleur
à chaque pays son processus de
réparation
et en nouvelle calédonie qu'est ce qu'on
a fait layton en mars elle est d'aider
les tatanes les joies ville et tous les
autres
ils en sont
pour ce qui est du contentieux colonial
avec la france
les mémoires ont été façonnés à tous les
niveaux
l'histoire est longtemps resté tabou
ce qui nous a plongés dans ce que
louis-josé barbançon appel pays du non
dit
est aujourd'hui à mon sens
nous en sommes là
la reconnaissance officielle de la
colonisation se trouve dans le préambule
de l'accord de nouméa
la première étape a donc été réalisée
la responsabilité française y figurent
il n'y est pas pleinement assumé
l'histoire calédonienne manque encore
cruellement de lumière
la troisième étape les excuses
officielles sans qu'il ne s'agisse de
repentance n'a jamais été abordé
mais paradoxalement alors même que les
étapes précédentes sont restées timides
quelques gestes de réparation ont été
menées
la réforme foncière
la remise de l'acte de possession
la démarche pour la place de la paix
et dernièrement le mémorial dédié à
hatay grand guerrier kanak
alors en tête un acte des processus des
rituels de réconciliation ont été menées
en 98 entre les familles des victimes de
la grotte d'ouvéa et les gendarmes en
2004 entre plusieurs familles autour de
l'assassinât de jean marie tjibaou et
irene irwin
et tout récemment en 2021 à fond houari
entre la foi et farineau
à la mémoire data et son sorcier entre
l'état et les instances coutumière
d'ailleurs dans la coutume kanak on
retrouve nos quatre étapes
la rencontre est souvent solennelle
en déposant une coutume de pardon la
partie fautive reconnaît les faits admis
ses responsabilités et demande pardon
ces trois étapes sont presque
simultanées
l'autre partie répond pour montrer
qu'elle accepte les excuses
et en guise de réparation une messe
oecuménique est donné
mais à l'échelle du pays il reste tant à
faire
il nous faut imaginer ce processus de
réparation calédonien comme l'a dit
récemment le haut commissaire de la
république en nouvelle-calédonie
il fut un temps où nous étions les uns
en face des autres
aujourd'hui il est temps d'être les uns
à côté des autres
avec l'association demain en commun nous
souhaitons mettre en place un processus
de justice transitionnelle pour le pays
notre idée s'inspirait des caravanes
espagnol de la mémoire un bus sillonnera
le pays pour récolter et faire voyager
la mémoire
pour en montrer la diversité et
revisiter l'histoire officielle
les mémoires seraient accueillis au sein
même de kunming et constituerait la
matière nécessaire aux prochaines étapes
du processus de réconciliation
nous souhaitons délier les langues
car le passé est devenu si lourd
l'empêchent le futur de se construire
le futur doit devenir le projet commun
en se basant en s'appuyant sur un passé
révélé
pardonner
réparer
sur un passé qu'on n'aura pas
étouffée
au leti merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]